[Music]  there's nothing too short that I can't  cameo goodness it's raining The  Adventures of parody man  [Music]  paper bag or triple mylar spider-man  first appeared in 1962 classic amazing  fantasy number 15  my beloved is napping blissfully in the  many folds of my spider-man t-shirt it's  not the present send my wife some  flowers and bring me an Advil okay Nick  Fury agent of schnapps okay  movies over the superheroes are friends  again let's get out of here  we can't leave before the post-credits  sequence chief Wiggum I'm assembling a  team of the best team assemblers in the  world and I want you to help me put  together that team assembler  there was a kid movies ended when they  ended the only reason you stayed for the  credits was to see who sang the power of  love and it was usually Huey Lewis  [Music]